[Música]
cuando tenemos miedo no está grande la
drena secreta adrenalina la adrenalina
lo que hace es que pone en turbo
nuestras funciones vitales como la del
ritmo cardíaco y la presión arterial
también tensa nuestros músculos como la
vejiga por eso no nos dan ganas de ir al
baño nuestras manos se ponen sudorosas y
frías porque la sangre ya no llega a
nuestras extremidades nuestro cuerpo no
reconoce la diferencia entre una amenaza
real y un indicio de una posible amenaza
entonces hablar en público
mi cuerpo actúa como si realmente fuera
una citación de vida o muerte por eso me
gusta la biología porque me hace
entender lo que sucede en mi cuerpo pero
también me hace entender lo que sucede
fuera de mi cuerpo
cuando estudia biología yo nunca me
imaginé al mundo a que viva de entrar
hoy les traigo un poco de este mundo y
les platico seis hits más importantes o
impactantes de la biología
en el número 1 tenemos a pasos de baile
tan buenos que salvan vidas veamos este
vídeo
[Música]
parece broma pero es cierto este es una
araña macho y es de la especie marató
solange la conocemos como araña pavo
real es de la familia salt y si de estoy
muy segura que la reconocen porque son
las arañas chiquititas que saltan de un
lugar a otro lo que vimos fue su cortejo
es la manera en que el macho atrae la
atención de la hembra
es importante que recordemos que las
arañas son caníbales entonces si paco en
este caso le vamos a llamar paco no hace
bien sus pasos puede atraer a la hembra
de una manera equivocada
veamos cómo le va en su cortejo
muy bien pasemos de hit número dos
hormigas zombies y es que esto suena
como de película a ciencia ficción pero
en realidad es cierto lo que tenemos
aquí es una hormiga que le vamos a
llamar arnoldo y aquí tenemos a un hongo
del género cordyceps los hongos son
hetero tropos es decir que consumen
organismos para sobrevivir se reproducen
por esporas y tienen un cuerpo
fructífero cuerpo fructífero suena raro
pero ustedes ya los conocen pueden tener
la forma de un champiñón o una seta en
este caso no todos los hongos tienen
cuerpo fructífero y no todos lucen como
champiñones z pero el cuerpo de kurt
fructífero de cordyceps luce así y les
voy a explicar cómo es que las hormigas
se vuelven zombies
tenemos ahí el cuerpo fructífero donde
están las esporas las esporas viajan y
se meten al foro del cuerpo de la
hormiga una vez que ese es por está
dentro de la hormiga germina y toma el
control del sistema nervioso de la
hormiga haciéndola treparse a un árbol y
encargar sus mandíbulas por siempre una
vez que hace esto el hongo va
consumiendo cada célula cada tejido y
cada órgano de la hormiga hasta que
tiene la energía suficiente para sacar
un cuerpo fructífero donde
posteriormente habrá esporas que serán
liberadas para consumir a otras hormigas
vamos a esperar porque quiero indicarles
algo esta pequeña bola que vemos ahí
tiene esporas y se ve chiquita pero en
realidad tiene millones de esporas y las
escuelas son tan ligeras y tan pequeñas
que el viento las puede mover varios
metros y colonizar otras hormigas una
vez que hay un hongo cordyceps cerca de
una colonia de hormigas esas hormigas ya
no tienen futuro hit número 3 y lo vamos
a llamar clonación perfecta este es uno
de mis animales favoritos es un
vertebrado y el nombre formal sería
ácido pero se conocen como pulgón si
ustedes tienen un huerto o una maceta
que les guste mucho y los han encontrado
puede apostar que los odian y es que el
principio un día ves uno la siguiente
día vez 50 se reproducen rapidísimo si
nos ponemos a pensar en nuestro libro
biología y hacer como enrique de las
reproducciones tenemos dos tipos la
sexual y la asexual estos pequeñines se
reproducen de las dos maneras
está este ácido se reproduce de la
manera asexual que se llama
partenogénesis que quiere decir da a luz
a un clon de ella misma este clon ya
tiene un embrión dentro de ella y es por
eso que se reproducen súper rápido si yo
les tuviera que dar un premio a alguien
se lo daría al ácido porque es una plaga
muy eficaz aunque no nos gustaría
tenerla nuestro jardín realmente como
plaga hace un muy buen trabajo puse a
dolly porque la clonación de dolly no
fue muy grata que digamos hit número 4
sweet ways esto es dulce excremento o
dulce desecho y es que seguimos hablando
de los ácidos porque ya saben entonces
quiénes son mis favoritos la boca del
ácido es como un popote y lo que hace es
que penetra el tejido de la planta una
vez que lo hace succiona la savia dentro
de la planta y aquí viene algo
importante en biología tenemos
relaciones simbióticas hay de distintos
tipos pero no nos vamos a enfocar en la
mutualista que es donde los dos
organismos se ven beneficiados
la hormiga cuando el ácido tiene su su
boca dentro del tejido lo que va a hacer
es que va a pasar
y del ácido y de la va a salir como un
líquido azucarado la hormiga se lo va a
comer le está en campo y entonces eso es
lo que la hormiga obtiene en la esa
relación con el ácido que es lo que va a
obtener el ácido las hormigas se
encargan de cuidar a la colonia de
áfidos de la planta donde ambos viven
esa es una relación mutualista una de
las más interesantes la verdad hubieran
visto mi cara una vez que me di cuenta
que mi planta de papa no solo está
infestada de pulgones sino que había
hormigas ahí ordenándolas y digo
ordenándolas porque es el término en
inglés que se utiliza cuando la hormiga
le aprieta su pancita que es para mí muy
bien vamos a el hit número 5 y estos son
los ositos de agua por favor quiero que
admiren las uñas de este animal es uno
de mis favoritos también y es un
invertebrado es tan pequeño pero cuando
digo pequeño en serio es pequeño la
especie más grande de estos está regados
puede llegar a medir 1.2 milímetros o
sea chiquititos también se conoce como
tardígrados o extremófila cuando digo
extremos realmente son extremos pueden
sobrevivir a ambientes
instalados pueden sobrevivir a ambientes
super ha sido súper calientes super
fríos hubo una investigación donde
dijeron los científicos pues hay que
mandarlos al espacio a ver si si
sobreviven sobrevivieron en serio y por
si no fuera poco tienen un as bajo la
manga éstos tardígrados cuando ya se
encuentran en un por fin en un ambiente
inhóspito para ellos que no pueden vivir
ahí lo que hacen es que reducen su agua
corporal de un 85% a un 3% o sea se auto
deshidratan convirtiéndose como una
pelotita como si fueran una pasta y ese
estado científicamente se llama como
cripto biosys pueden durar años así una
vez que están de nuevo en contacto con
el ambiente y las condiciones son
perfectas lo único que hacen es
reabsorberse 85% de la corporal y siguen
con lo suyo
último hit este es el número 6 con los
taquitos al pastor no te metas pero si
les voy a contar algo de los técnicos
del pastor ahí también me gustan pero si
es necesario que lo sepan al menos a mi
parecer lo que tenemos ahí es una
solitaria que estoy muy segura que la
han escuchado hablar y es que hace 20
años así estragos en nuestro país con 6
mil casos de tenía sis al año le decimos
tenía así es porque su nombre científico
es tenia solium y pues aquí le vamos a
llamar nacho hay dos cosas de la tenga
que me encanta una es su ciclo de vida
que es un tanto complicado por ahorita
se los voy a tratar de resumir y
explicar y la otra es el tipo de
reproducción que tiene para empezar
déjenme enseñarles cómo realmente luce
una técnica
ok esta sería como no no escala esto
sería realmente el lo largo que puede
crecer una tenía dentro de nosotros
puede llegar a medir 4 metros y es así
planeta de hecho sus nombres en su está
dentro de un grupo que se llama
platelmintos que son gusanos planos así
luce la tenia y de una parte la parte de
arriba en su cabecita que se va a llamar
propiamente es cólex tiene ganchitos su
cuerpo que es de 4 metros está
segmentado y cada segmento nuevo hace 20
que va creciendo es desde la cabecita
hasta el extremo
entonces los segmentos del extremo son
los que están maduros y los segmentos
que están cerca de la cabecita son los
relativamente nuevos pero les voy a
explicar su ciclo de vida entonces en
méxico a veces riegan las fresas y los
cilantros con agua tratada agua tratada
significa que pueden llegar a tener si
se pueden llegar a tener bolsillos de
parásitos y puede ser el caso de tena
así es como luce un huevecillo de tema
entonces digamos que mis maría se queda
son hacerlas con crema pero palabras que
importan como las fresas están
deliciosas el bolsillo es tan pequeño
que yo no me percato que lo consumir y
va hacia mi tracto digestivo eclosión en
mi panza y sale de ahí una pequeña larbi
está que con sus ganchos se enganchen
intestino como les dije tiene un gran
potencial la tenía puede llegar a medir
4 metros y mi intestino mide más o menos
6 metros entonces pues la tenía está
feliz y coma el problema es que a una
persona que padece teniasis cada que
defeca no solo defeca heces fecales sino
que también defeca esos pequeños
segmentos estresan al extremo y cada
segmento puede llegar a tener 100 a
miles de huevecillos de tema y es así
como se sigue el ciclo puede tener una
variante si llega un cerdo y se come un
follaje que tiene esos huevecillos y sus
huevecillos ya no se van a su tracto
digestivo se esconden en el músculo del
cerdo y misma área va por unos taquitos
esos taquitos no están bien conocidos y
yo me voy a comer un huevo
tenía que está enquistado en un músculo
se llama ahora cisticerco y en vez de
que se produzca alguna el hombre es de
esta magnitud de mi estómago el cities
cisticerco va a viajar a donde no está
el sistema inmune tan activo en mi
cuerpo que es mi cerebro y eso puede
provocar una neurocisticercosis lo cual
es bastante peligroso
lo que más me gusta de lo que doble que
les conté es que yo soy mucho más me
parezco mucho más estos organismos de lo
que creo todos tanto la tenia como el
tar de grado como el ácido cordyceps
hormiga y la araña todos tienen células
y están hechos de las mismas
biomoléculas que yo de lípidos de
proteínas de carbohidratos de ácidos
nucleicos todos todos todos tienen sus
células que forman tejidos tejidos que
forman órganos y órganos que forman
sistemas yo siempre que he creído que
cuando tú estudias alguna carrera tú
sales como con el chip de esa carrera y
es que eso me pasó con la biología al
finalizar mi carrera de biología no hay
manera que yo no aprecié la espora de un
cordis eps o las uñas de un tardígrados
es maravilloso la biodiversidad que hay
y esto se debe a pequeños accidentes
genéticos que tuvieron que haber pasado
en nuestro adn espero les haya gustado
mi plástica hayan aprendido de la
biología y sino que al menos piensen dos
veces antes de consumir taquitos al
pastor
[Aplausos]